foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing the 10 largest magical
creatures the behemoths of The Wizarding
World this list was particularly
difficult to make as the exact
specifications of each creature height
weight Etc are not easy to come by
suffice to say the honorable mentions
list following the main list is pretty
long as well I don't think you'll be
able to guess all 10 but leave a comment
down below before you start and see if
you're right at the end anyway I won't
dawdle here are the 10 most enormous
magical creatures 10. Giants ironically
the aptly named giant is the smallest
creature on this list but that's a rare
position for them to be in Giants are
incredibly powerful creatures that tend
to live out their lives in tribes
completely separate from the rest of the
Wizarding Community they are smarter
than trolls stupider than humans and
their innate bloodthirsty Nature has
typically resulted in their own
population control the secret to Giant's
power is in their name they are giant in
fact they are larger than almost any
other magical creature equal in physical
strength to dragons and highly resistant
to spells Giants can grow to be
approximately 20 to 25 feet in height
which puts the largest Giants at about
twice the size of Hagrid who is 12 feet
tall what's important to note however is
that Robbie Coltrane in the films was
portrayed to be eight foot six therefore
the actual size of giants is about three
times what we see from Hagrid on screen
nine three-headed dog they were looking
straight into the eyes of a monstrous
dog a dog that filled the whole space
between ceiling and floor it had three
heads three pairs of rolling mad eyes
three noses twitching and quivering in
their Direction
three drooling mouths saliva hanging in
Slippery robes from yellowish fangs the
creature described above is of course
fluffy Hagrid's three-headed dog that
once guarded the Philosopher's Stone
three-headed dogs were very rare
creatures that held from Greece the
introduction of fluffy in Harry Potter
is undoubtedly an homage to Cerberus or
The Hound of Hades from Greek mythology
given that fluffy filled the whole space
between ceiling and floor and that
Hogwarts boasted some impressively high
ceilings I'd be willing to bet that
fluffy was at least 25 to 30 feet tall
eight horned serpent horned serpents are
large horned magical snakes with a few
different variations in species that
inhabit bodies of water and possess all
sorts of unusual abilities their horns
are used in one cause and was notably
used in the wand of ilvermorny founder
is old Sayer the core of these ones by
vibrates when parcel tongue is being
spoken and warns the owner of danger by
emitting a low musical tone horned
serpents also exist outside of Harry
Potter in folklore and the general
consensus is that these creatures are at
least 30 feet in length and weigh over
one thousand pounds 7. irumpent irumpens
are large gray African beasts that may
be mistaken for a rhinoceros at a
distance they have thick hides that
repel most charms and curses a large
sharp horn upon its nose and a long
rope-like tail and a rampant does appear
in Fantastic Beasts and let me just say
that this thing is colossal in fact it's
been expressed that female arampans can
grow up to five times the size of a
non-magical hippopotamus which has a
similar body type this would put the
largest a rampants at nearly 7.5 meters
in height and almost 15 meters in length
the rampant is listed as a medium-sized
creature in some places but that is
simply untrue 6. basilisk basilisks are
enormous Serpentine creatures that were
originally created by a dark wizard by
the name of Harpo The fowl of the many
fearsome beasts and monsters that roam
our land there is none more Curious or
more deadly than the Basilisk known also
as the king of serpents this snake which
may reach gigantic size and live many
hundreds of years is born from a
chicken's egg hatched beneath a toad its
methods of killing our most wondrous for
aside from its steadily and venomous
fangs the Basilisk has a murderous stare
and all who are fixed with the beam of
its eye shall suffer instant death
spiders flee before the Basilisk for it
is their mortal enemy and the Basilisk
flees only from the crowing of the
rooster which is fatal to it in size
basilisks are enormous creatures growing
up to 50 feet in length on some accounts
60 feet not only that but they're the
Ultimate Weapon possessing giant fangs
protective scales and a gaze that can
kill you instantly the Basilisk used in
the film was about 80 feet in length
according to prop Creator Robert Blairs
so if you want to imagine the real size
subtract about 37.5 percent 5. dragons
there's no wave watched or read Harry
Potter without seeing or reading about a
dragon or two dragons are giant winged
fire breathing beasts that incite fear
in the hearts of even bravest witches
and wizards they play an integral role
in this series and are even mentioned in
the Hogwarts motto dracon dormin nanquam
Didi Landes which literally translates
to never tickle a sleeping dragon
dragons also bear the potential to be
extremely destructive classified as a
category 5x Beast by the ministry of
magic
but whether they fall in terms of the
largest creatures to uncover that we'll
have to figure out what type of dragon
in Harry Potter there are all sorts of
dragons referenced hailing from all
different locations but as it turns out
the three biggest are the Norwegian
Ridgeback hebridian black and of course
the Behemoth that is the Ukrainian iron
belly the Norwegian Ridgeback and
hebridium black are roughly 30 feet in
length and the Ukrainian iron belly is
doubled at at 60 feet I'd also like to
give an honorable mention here to
women's as they fall somewhat into the
same category as dragons 4. giant squid
giant squids also exist in the Muggle
world but the one in Harry Potter is
purported to be magical in some capacity
and that's why it's on this list the
giant squid in Harry Potter lived in the
great lake near the grounds of Hogwarts
Castle and despite the squid being
portrayed as a fair inspiring symbol the
giant squid near Hogwarts was actually
rather tame a self-domesticated creature
that did nothing but occasionally play
with students while muggle giant squids
are somewhere in the realm of 12 to 13
meters long for females the one in Harry
Potter is supposed to be upwards of 70
feet not bad 3. sea serpent sea serpents
were aquatic magical beasts of immense
size found in oceans all across the
world in appearance they have a
snake-like body paired with a horse-like
head as well as rows of sharp teeth but
despite their immense size and capacity
to do damage sea serpents much like the
giant squid have a fairly peaceful
temperament but just how big rc7s
apparently over 100 feet this makes them
the largest creatures on this list so
far by a huge margin they are absolutely
colossal but if you happen to find
yourself near one fear not as there have
been no reported attacks on man or
wizard kind 2. nundu next up we have the
nundu noon Do's are magical beasts
somewhat resembling a line that have a
reputation for being the most
destructive and Powerful creatures in
the entire Wizarding World at least when
they're Untamed but how big are they
well this one's a bit of a mess because
the nundu has been very differently
portrayed from book to film you see the
nundu actually appears in both the book
and film versions of Fantastic Beasts
but they are not even remotely
consistent with one another in their
portrayal in the films the nundu is
certainly large but nothing even
remotely comparable to the upper
echelons of this list the book however
shows the nundu as an absolutely
colossal creature that dwarves
everything on the list with the
exception of the number one spot there's
also some Canon that perhaps backs up
just how massive the nundu is apparently
it takes up to 100 witches and wizards
working together to subdue a nundu where
it only takes a dozen to stun a dragon
this could be relevant to the creature's
size but this fact in conjunction with
how it is portrayed in the book and
tells me that it probably really is
quite massive it's also quite possible
that the small nundu in newt's
Commander's briefcase was simply
underdeveloped because it was young 1.
Okami I know what you're thinking Okami
is the largest creatures let me explain
first of all what is an Okami the Okami
is found in the Far East and India a
plumed two-legged winged creature with a
serpentine body it feeds mainly on rats
and birds though has been known to carry
off monkeys the occamy is aggressive to
all who approach it particularly in
defense of its eggs and while the Okami
may not look particularly impressive it
does possess one exceptionally powerful
ability it grows to fit available space
this ability is referred to as granap
Texas so while the Okami may not look
particularly large in some environments
its capacity to grow means that it could
technically outgrow any other creature
provided the space is big enough
and that concludes a list creatures that
narrowly miss the list include Acro
mantulas at 15 feet yetis at 15 feet
trolls at 12 feet manticores at 10 to 15
feet chimeras grap horns sphinxers
Thunderbirds raims and blast ended
screws to name a handful if you enjoy
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember imperfect understanding is
often more dangerous than ignorance
[Music]